START- BECAUSE WE HAVE REGULAR
ORDER BUSINESS PRIOR TO. WHY IS
IT WHAT WE HAVE AN ECHO- PRIOR
TO THIS SUSPENSE FILE WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND START
WITH OUR REGULAR ORDER OF
BUSINESS POWERFUL I KNOW IT
SOUNDS. I DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN
FIX THAT THAT'S GOING TO REALLY
IRRITATE ME. WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE TO GET
THROUGH THESE- STARTING WITH
MISTER WEST SO IS I THINK FIRST
THE- THREE CAN WE GET THERE
YEAH. SENATORWAS A WHEN THERE
ARE ENOUGH PEOPLE HERE YOU DO
IT ENJOY A DUE PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON SB THREE
NINETY FOUR SO- DON'T FEEL THE
NEED TO TAKE UP TOO MUCH TIME
BUT PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION. HOLD HOLD PLEASE
I ACTUALLY HAVE A QUORUM. THANK
YOU. RIGHT NOW IT'S OKAY I'M
SORRY IT'S ALWAYS A GOOD DAY
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM AND
SECRETARY FOR THE ROLE GONZALEZ
PRESENT BIGELOW BRIAN CALDERON
CORREO CHAU DALAI DAVIES ON
GABRIEL WATER GARCIA LEVINE
BURKE YEAH ROBERT RIVAS WEBER
KALRA VACANCY. AND SINCE WE ARE
NOW IN AN ACTUAL MEETING I NEED
TO DO THE HOUSEKEEPING VERY
QUICK I'M SORRY CENTER WEST SO-
OF COURSE WE ARE GONNA BITE IT
BY ALL THE RULES OF- THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WHICH
MEANS IF YOU'RE IN THIS ROOM
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A MASK ON A IF
YOU ARE ON THE PHONES- WE ONLY
TAKE AND LET'S YOU'D BEEN
LISTED AS A WITNESS BEFORE
TODAY WE ONLY TAKE YOUR NAME
YOUR POSITION AND AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE- WE ARE NOT WE HAVE A LOT
OF THINGS TO GET THROUGH TODAY
SO WE ARE GOING TO BE VERY
STRICT ON THAT IF YOU VIOLATE
THE RULES THEN. YOU WILL GIVE
UP YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
TO COMMENT SO WITH THAT WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO CENTER WEBSITE
THE MOTION BY MISS CARILLO AND
A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK YOU
MAY PROCEED. YES ON WORLD ON
THE TELEPHONE OF LIFELINE THE
LITTLE DALLAS AND YEAH BOB WELL
THE TOP OF THE STAIRS AND ROMAN
THE LIE FOR WE WERE TO MAKE
THIS PRO MORE X. TO IN THE
COMMUNITY THIS BILL. UP WILL.
ENSURE THAT- THIS THIS- PROGRAM
GETS OF FULLY ENROLLED I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND THERE HAVE BEEN NO
NO VOTES OF STATE WITH THIS
BILL I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT ANDLET'S GET THIS
PROGRAM WORKING FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU- WILL
GO AHEAD AND GO TO THE PHONE
LINES IS THERE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB.
THREE NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THERE'S NO
ONE WHO IS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU WE
WILL- I SEE NOBODY IN THE
GALLERY COMING UP WE WILL GO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF
THEY'RE AVAILABLE. MORNING
CHAIR GONZALEZ VICE CHAIR
BIGELOW AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
MILLION WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE WE HAVE NO POSITION
ON THIS BILL THE CQC NOT SNOW
FISCAL IN ITS STATE OPERATIONS
FROM THIS BILL. THE C. P. U. C.
WAS UNABLE TO PROVIDE AN
ESTIMATE ON INCREASE
PARTICIPATION COSTS FROM THIS
BILL- THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN
UNKNOWN COST PRESSURE ON THE
UNIVERSAL LIFELINE PHONE TRUST
ADMINISTRATIVE COMMITTEE FUND-
IF THERE IS AN INCREASE TO
PARTICIPATION IN THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM FINANCE NOTES ANY COSTS
FROM THE SPILL I DO TO INCREASE
PARTICIPATION MAY EXACERBATE AN
EXISTING STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN
THE WITHIN THE LIFELINE FUND
WHICH HAS BEEN IN I A
CONSISTENT YEAR OVER YEAR
DECLINE IN SURCHARGE REVENUES
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
PROGRAM HAD A BUDGET OF FOUR
HUNDRED TEN MILLION DOLLARS
WHILE ONLY COLLECTING THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU I'M WITHOUT I SEE NO
COMMENT YOUR BILL GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HAVE
SENATOR ROTH GENERAL RUSS- YOU
HAVE SB SIX TWENTY NINE IT HAS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION OF A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO SECOND
BY DOCTOR QUIRKY MAY PROCEED.
THANK MANAGER MEMBERS- THE BILL
GIVES THOSE INMATES RELEASED
FROM A CITY OUR FACILITY CDCR
FACILITY IN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA IDENTIFICATION CARD
OR OF QUALIFIED A RENEWAL I SEE
A RENEWAL OF THE CALIFORNIA
DRIVER'S LICENSE BILLS COST
NEUTRAL AND RESPECT FOR YOUR
SURVIVAL THANK YOU WILL GO TO
THE FRONT LINES ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB SIX
TWENTY NINE. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
NINE ZERO. FINALLY CHAIR
KNOWING THE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK HERE I SEE NOBODY
IN THE GALLERY AND THEN WE WILL
GO TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FINANCE HAS NO POSITION ON THIS
BILL- CDCR AND THE DMV INDICATE
MINOR AND AFFORDABLE COSTS TO
THIS BILL. THANK YOU I SEE NO
DISCUSSION. WILL TAKE OUT OF
YOUR CLOTHES. YES MA'AM THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL WITH MR
BIGELOW VOTING NO NEXT WE WILL
HAVE MR STERN MR STERN IS-
PRESENTING ON SB FIVE THIRTY
THREE TO ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO SECOND BY
DOCTORS WORK YOU MAY PROCEED.
AT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- THIS BILL CONCERNS
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT DOWNS
AND HOPEFULLY BRINGS MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO THE PROCESS
THEREBY- BRING MINOR TO ABSORB
ALL COSTS A TO THE OFFICE OF
ENERGY AND INFRASTRUCTURE. AS
WELL AS TO I'LL USE IN THEIR
ANNUAL WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PLANS WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I'VE OF THANK YOU IT SAYS
YOU HAVE A WITNESS ARE I'M SURE
THE WITNESSES JUST IF WE NEED
QUESTIONS ANSWERED YES THAT'S
CORRECT THANK YOU- SO THANK YOU
FOR I KNOW JEAN HURST IS WHEN
IS BUT SHE IS SHE I ASSUME YES-
IS- HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF
NOT WE'LL JUST GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE THIRTY
THREE. AND AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE ARE NOW GOING
TO GO TO THE PHONE LINE OF MINE
FIFTY TWO. HI THIS IS JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SURE THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU- WITH THAT
WILL BRING IT BACK I SEE NOBODY
GETTING UP IN THIS ROOM SO
WE'LL TAKE IT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE BINANCE HAS NO
POSITION ON THIS BILL THE
OFFICE OF ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
SAFETY AND THE C. P. C. S. NO
FISCAL IMPACT FROM THIS BILL.
AND WE DO NOT ANTICIPATE A
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'LL TAKE
THIS IS YOUR CLOSE MR DURING
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH VICE CHAIR BIGELOW VOTING
NO- I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GOING
TO PRESENT AS WELL FOR MR
MCGUIRE SB THREE FORTY ONE
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
OF A MOTION BY. MISS CARILLO
SECOND BY DR CORKY MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MANAGER OF THIS BILL
CONCERNS WILDFIRES AGAIN AND-
IN TELECOMMUNICATIONS OUTAGES
OF THE COST OF THE P. C. IN
CARILLO YES WILL BE MINOR TO
ABSORB MOBILE AND YET PROVIDE
IMPORTANT CERTAINTY COMMUNITIES
COUNTING ON BACK UP POWER TO
CELL TOWERS. AND LANDLINE
OPERATIONS THE CABLE PHONE
SYSTEMS EVERYWHERE COULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU WE WILL TAKE IT TO THE
PHONE LINES ANYBODY AND SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO SB THREE FORTY
ONE. WE DO WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE SIXTY VERY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN MEMBERS MARKS
LEFT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY NUMBER
ASSOCIATION OTHERWISE KNOWN OF
NINE ONE ONE DISPATCHERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LINE FIFTY KILL. THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN I'M SORRY
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC AGAIN
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE. SIXTY SIX.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DAMON CONKLIN- WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE. FORTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING DOCTOR
HARTMAN WITH- CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICT ASSOCIATION YEAH IT'S
ON THE COURT THANK YOU LINE.
SIXTY FIVE. VENTURE MEMBERS
CHRISTIE VELMA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE FINAL CALL FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU I'M WE WILL BRING IT BACK I
SEE NOBODY IN THE AUDIENCE
WISHING TO SPEAK DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FINANCE HAS NO FILE ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU. I WILL
TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES THAT
ALSO GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH VICE CHAIR BIGELOW VOTING
NO. BECAUSE AND ALL KINDS OF
PROBLEMS TODAY ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU MR STERN MISTER TIE THOUGH-
BECAUSE YOU'RE PRESENTING ON A
SUSPENSE BILL WE'RE GONNA TAKE
REGULAR ORDER BUSINESS FIRST-
SO DR PANAS HERE ABOUT HOW TO
TAKE DOCTOR PAN- IT'S HIGHLY
UNUSUAL TO PRESENT ON A
SUSPENSE BUILT. ON THE DAY OF
SUSPENSE BUT WE OF COURSE WILL
ALLOW YOU TO DO SO. DR PAN- SB
TWO TWENTY SIX ENJOY TE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO SECOND
BY DOCTOR QUIRKY MAY PROCEED.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF
MEMBERS- PLEASE RESENT SB TWO
TWO SIX A DISTRICT BILL WHICH
CODIFIES A PROCESS FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY HEALTH
AUTHORITY TO WORK WITH THE PART
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND OF
COMEY PROCUREMENT OF
COMMERCIAL. AND MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS OKAY
SERVICES TO SPACE THERE'S NO
STATE COSTS ASSOCIATED THIS
BILL THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL
SPONSORED BY THE COUNTY
SACRAMENTO AND SO FAR AS
RECEIVED IN AS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. SB I VOTE AND I DO
HAVE A WITNESS- CHIFFON QATARI
HEALTH SERVICE DIRECTOR FOR
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OUT IN
SUPPORT IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
SO THE WITNESSES HERE JUST IN
CASE WE HAVE QUESTIONS CORRECT
OKAY WITH THAT WILL GO TO THE
FINAL ON THE PHONE LINES. BUT
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO SB TWO TWENTY SIX. FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. PRESS. ONE NINE
ZERO. MADAM CHAIR NO ONE IS
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
WONDERFUL THAT'S WHAT I LIKE TO
HEAR I'M WITH THAT WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT I SEE NOBODY IN THE
ROOM GETTING UP TO SPEAK SO
WE'LL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FINANCES NEUTRAL ON
THIS BILL THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES
NO FISCAL IMPACT FROM THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
CHECK IT OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU NOT A FAN. WE HAVE
DOCTOR QUIRK IS GOING TO
PRESENT FOR MR WHITE HOUSE SKI
SB FIVE SEVENTY ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION OF A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO IN A SECOND BY.
MISTER KALRA THANK YOU CHAIRED
MEMBERS SB FIVE SEVENTY IS A
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP OF
CALIFORNIA'S VEHICLE CODE QUICK
WITH LIST. OF THE BILL'S FISCAL
COST IS NEGLIGIBLE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE ARRIVE OF
THANK YOU WILL GO AHEAD AND GO
TO THE FRONT LINES ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB.
FIVE SEVENTY. IT WAS TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO. I AM
CHAIR KNOWING THE SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
ALL I WILL GO TO THE I SEE
NOBODY IN- THE ROOM GETTING UP
SO WE WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT
FINANCE FINANCES NEUTRAL ON
THIS BILL THE DMV AND CHP
ANTICIPATE NO FISCAL IMPACT OF
THIS BILL. THAT'S WONDERFUL
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
DOCTOR COURT THANK YOU FOR
PRESENTING FOR MR WHY CASKEY I
WOULD NOTE- TO MISS RUBIO SHE
AND I I'M GONNA PRESENT FOR MR
PORTANTINO BUT SHE IS THE LAST
REGULAR ORDER BUSINESS. AUTHORS
OF HER STAFF IS WATCHING THIS
WAY IF WE COULD GET MISS RUBIO
HERE THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL- OR
SOMEBODY COULD PRESENT ON HER
HALF BEHALF IF. ANYBODY ONE
STATE LET ME DO MISTER
PORTANTINO'S AND IF IT MISS
RUBIO IS NOT HERE WILL GO AHEAD
AND HAVE YOU PRESENT DOCTOR
PARK ON HER BEHALF RIGHT. THANK
YOU DID. SO THE CHAIR'S GONNA
PERCENT ON SB. SIX THREE ONE.
THIS GREAT PRESENTATION. THE
CITY WIND WILL GO TO THE PHONES
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
AND AGAIN ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN TERRIBLE
THIS IS A CLAIMS BILL SORRY.
WHEN THE SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK NO ONE WISHING TO
SPEAK WILL GO TO THE AUDIENCE
DOES ANYONE WISH TO ADDRESS US
ON THIS BILL THIS IS SIX THIRTY
ONE PORTANTINO THE STATE CLAIMS
BILL SAYING NO ONE RALLY TO THE
CALL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF.
FINANCE FINANCE SUPPORTS THIS
BILL I THINK YOU SEE POSITIVE
THOUGHT OKAY GOING TO MEMBERS
TO ANY MEMBER HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I WILL I WILL BE
RIGHT NOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I WOULD JUST TO REMIND
PEOPLE THAT AMOUNT SPENT
NINETEEN YEARS IN JAIL BECAUSE
OF PROSECUTORIAL MISINFORMATION
IF YOU WILL- ANOTHER INJUSTICE
AND WE SEE A LOT OF THESE EVERY
YEAR SO I'M GLAD HE IS GETTING
SOME RELIEF BUT WE CAN'T COME
BACK AS YEARS RESPECT LAST FOR
AN AYE VOTE FANTASTIC THE BILL
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL BRING
IT BACK TO S. B. THREE TEN
MINUTES RUBIO ARE YOU ON YOUR
WAY. THE PROPERTY ONE OF. SINCE
WE HAVE ART SUCH A LONG DAY
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET THAT
DONE THIS IS TECHNICAL ANYWAY-
SB THREE TEN YES SB THREE TED
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO AND A
SECOND BY- MISTER KALRA. NYNEX
THE CANCER MEDICATION RECYCLING
ACT TO PROMOTE THAT SHE JUST
GOT HERE SO WE WERE JUST GOING
TO PASS YOUR BILL MISS RUBIO.
YEP WHERE ARE YOU EA ARE YOU
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE IT TO
THE PHON LINES. YES PLEASE
THANK YOU THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE TEN.
FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. MADAM CHAIR NO ONE A
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO STAY
WONDERFUL SCENE NOBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WISHES TO SPEAK
WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FINANCE HAS NO POSITION
ON THIS BILL THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ANTICIPATES
MINOR AND ABSORBABLE COSTS. FOR
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
AND- STEEL PATH MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA. THE PHARMACY
BOARD WILL INCUR ANNUAL COSTS
OF NINETY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR- PHARMACY BOARD
CONTINGENT FUND. FOR A HALFTIME
INSPECTOR POSITION. THE
DEPARTMENT HAS NOT YET
CONFIRMED IF THE CURRENT
LICENSE FEE FOR A SURPLUS
MEDICATION COLLECTION AND
DISTRIBUTION INTERMEDIARY IS
SUFFICIENT. TO COVER ADDITIONAL
COSTS OF THIS BILL OR IF A FEE
INCREASE MAY BE NEEDED THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU I SEE NO
DISCUSSION HERE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE CENTER RUBIO.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU THANK IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MR BIGELOW NOT
VOTING CONTRARIAN TODAY ALL
RIGHT THAT I'LL TAKE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR I HAVE
A MOTION BY MISCREANT A SECOND
BY MISS DAVIES AND IT CAN YOU
PLEASE READ THE BILL FOR THE
CONTRACT HONORED SB THREE OUT
SB THREE OH TWO CANADIAN
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION SB
SEVEN TWO TWO MELENDEZ THOSE
GET OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK
YOU I'M THAT THAT IS ALL THE
THINGS THAT WILL BE VOTING ON
NOW- WE WILL BE MOVING IN THE
REST OF THE BILLS TO SUSPENSE-
CENTER TYLER HE'S ASKED TO
PRESENT ON A BILL THAT IS BEING
MOVED TO SUSPENSE WHICH IN OUR
NEXT MEETING. OUR CONTINUATION
OF THIS MEETING WE WILL-
DISPENSE OF AT THAT TIME SO
MISTER TACO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS IS AN UNUSUAL TO
PRESENT- THIS THIS BILL DOES
MOMENT- BUT I WANT TO. THANK
YOU FOR AT THE TIME TO A
PRESENT ON AN IMPORTANT MATTER.
AS YOU KNOW WESTERN STATES ARE
FOR YOU SEEN A MEGA DROUGHT.
AND NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE INVEST IN
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE. FIRST
FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE
CALDERON FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS MEASURE BUT- I ALSO WANT
TO. SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL IN THE PAST THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MADE WISE
DECISIONS TO INVEST IN
REPAIRING OUR- CRUMBLING HIGH
RISK INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING
THE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN-
APPROPRIATION OF OVER ONE
BILLION. FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
OF THE NEW BAY BRIDGE BETWEEN
THE SAN FRANCISCO AND OAKLAND.
DESPITE THE AT THE- UNDER%
ESTIMATED COSTS THE STATE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE PROJECT
BECAUSE AS ONE OF THE MOST
HEAVILY TRAVELED BRIDGES IN OUR
STATE. IT WAS NECESSARY TO
REPAIR AND PROVIDED A NET
BENEFIT FOR THE ENTIRE STATE TO
DO SO. AN INVESTMENT IN OUR
FAMILY WATER DELIVERY SYSTEM IS
NO LESS IMPORTANT TO OUR STATE
AND TO ALL OF US THAT LIVE
HERE. WE GROW CROPS THAT FEED
THE WORLD. BUT THIS IS NOT JUST
FOR AGRICULTURE THE WATER IS
USED BY RESIDENTS IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND URBAN USERS IN LOS
ANGELES. ABOUT THIRTY ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THOUGH
THIS BILL ISN'T JUST ABOUT
AGRICULTURE LET'S NOT DISCOUNT
THE IMPACT THIS LEGISLATION
WILL HAVE ON OUR AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY I'VE THEIR FARMING
CONTRIBUTES FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
EVERY YEAR AND THAT'S WITHOUT
ACCOUNTING. FOR THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT ON FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE STATE.
IN CALIFORNIA WE RECOGNIZE OUR
STRATEGIC ADVANTAGES IN CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES AND HAVE ACTED TO
ENSURE THAT THEY STAY STRONG-
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
LEGISLATURE HAS ALLOCATED ONE.
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS TO
FILM AND TELEVISION PRODUCTIONS
TO ENSURE THOSE PRODUCTION STAY
HERE. THAT'S THREE HUNDRED AND-
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
AND I SUPPORT IT WE NEED THOSE
JOBS IN OUR STATE. BUT JUST
LIKE HOLLYWOOD CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY IS A
WORLD LEADER THREE OF OUR FOUR
LARGEST AGRICULTURE PRODUCING
COUNTIES IN THE UNITED STATES
ARE IN MY SENATE DISTRICT WE
NEED THE JOBS THIS INDUSTRY
SUPPORTS. TO AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY. CALIFORNIA NEEDS
THE FOOD. THAT THIS INDUSTRY
PRODUCES. THE NATION THAT AT
NEEDS THIS FOOD. SB FIVE AND I
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY NOT
ONLY TO PLAN FOR FUTURE WHICH
PROTECTED AS WELL. AND HERE IN
SUPPORT OR TO TESTIFY TO
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
ALEX BERING FROM THE PRIOR
ORDER AUTHORITY THANK YOU WILL
GO TO WITNESS AND SOMETHING YOU
AND- OH SORRY HI I'M ALEX
HEARING FROM FRESHWATER THIRTY
THANK YOU SENATOR RIGHT THAT
KIND OF- SPOKE OVER THAT THE
MODERATOR HERE BUT- JUST WANTED
TO SAY GOOD MORNING TO THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND KNOWING
WHAT'S ON THE AGENDA I JUST
LIKE THE OFFER MYSELF UP TO
ANSWERING TECHNICAL QUESTIONS-
ON THIS BILL WE'RE SPONSORED
THE BILL AND- HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN AND- THE LATEST
ATTEMPT- IN THE PAST HAVE TO
PASS SOMETHING SIMILAR SO. AT
ANY RATE- HAPPENED ANSWER
QUESTIONS OTHERWISE I'LL I'LL
JUST LET EVERYONE KEEP MOVING
FORWARDTHANK YOU. I THINK WE
HAVE A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL. MY CLIENTS FROM THE
AUDUBON SOCIETY YOU SEE ONLINE
YES THANK YOU. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING OF ON MY CLIENT PROJECT
OF QUALITY BOTTOM LINE
CALIFORNIA A DEPUTY TODAY AND
QUICKLY STAFFORD CONVENIENT THE
CONVERSATION CAN TAKE ORDERS ON
THE BAIL- AUDUBON CONCERNS
REALLY ARE CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH
THOSE THAT WERE IDENTIFIED IN
THE COMMITTEE STAFF REQUIRED-
WE THINK THAT SB FIVE FIVE NINE
CAN BE AMENDED SUPPORT PROPER
CARE WHILE ALSO PROMOTING
PUBLIC BENEFITS. PROVIDING
OVERSIGHT AND IN SHARING THEIR
ABILITY TO STATE INVESTMENT.
NOW WE KNOW THAT THE PROPOSED-
COMPANION FEDERAL LEGISLATION
WILL BECOME A MORE DETAILED
ANOTHER ELEMENT. AND A QUIET
COMPLIANCE WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
BE CLEAR AND WE HAD LOTS OF
PROFIT WE KNOW THE TELLING OF
THAT NEED TO BE REPAIRED THE
COMPETITION AND PROMPT MANNER-
AND THERE NEEDS TO BE PUBLIC
FUNDS. THE LOTS OF COMPLAINTS
HAD REAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
PEOPLE AND FARMS AND FUNDING
FOR THE DRINKING WATER SUPPLY.
NOT BECAUSE FIVE FIVE NINE
DOESN'T REQUIRE. A
DEMONSTRATION OF MEDICAL
BENEFITS EIGHT LOCAL WATER ON
OUT TO LEFT THE PATH IS A MY
OKAY CAN DANCE IS TO IMPROVE
AND OTHER BENEFITS SUCH AS
PROVIDING SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER YEAH FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT THAT'S WHAT WE
ALL WANT TO KNOW THE BILL LACK
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE AN ADEQUATE
CAUGHT A COST SHARE FOR PRIVATE
BENEFICIARY- ESPECIALLY IT DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE PRIVATE PARTY
TO THE RESPONSIBLE TO HISTORIC
AND ONGOING OVERDRAFT. IF I
JUST BE IDENTIFIED AND WHERE
APPROPRIATE THAT THEY
CONTRIBUTE ACOSTA THE REPAIRS.
THAT FIVE FIVE NINE THIS IS NOT
A FIVE EIGHT I'D BETTER FIND
COLLECTING COMITATO PARTY.
BECAUSE PUBLIC TAX DOLLARS FILL
THE VOID. HI REISSUE THE
SPECIALLY PRESENTLY HAVE A
CRACKING I SHOULD SAY BECAUSE
FIND AT THE KILLING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN ELEMENTS
FROM THE POPULAR PARTY. THAT
ITS STATE WILL REDUCE THE COST
HAVE A PRIVATE LOCAL
BENEFICIARIES. BUT NOT FOR
TAXPAYERS FINE FIVE FIVE NINE
LET LANGUAGE PROTECT THE STATE
INVESTMENT QUANTICO THE TRAFFIC
I THINK OPINION AND DAMAGE TO
OUR OF WHAT FURTHER TAX AND
THAT MEANT STATED MAY OUT HERE
TO DRAFT TO ADDRESS OVER IN
NEAR TERM AND AVOID AND
ADVOCATE THIRTY SIX VERSION SIR
FIVE FIVE NINE CAN NEARLY
BILLION IN STATE FUNDS WITHOUT
OVERSIGHT AND TRANSPARENCY AND
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPAIR AND MODERNIZE THE WATER
CAN BE INSTRUCTORS. IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS AND ENHANCES
PUBLIC BENEFIT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS.
MODERATE IT OPERATOR. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER LINES BUT THE BOOK
PARDON ME MISTER CHAIR DID YOU
WANNA GO TO THE PHONE LINES ARE
ARE YOU ASKING ME IF THERE WAS
AN ADDITIONAL WITNESS ON. OUR
THERE WRE THOSE WERE THE ONLY
LISTED WITNESSES WE HAD- GOING
TO THE PHONE LINE CASE OR
ANYONE IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THAT WISHES TO ADDRESS YES WE
DO HAVE SEVERAL SEVERAL PHONE
LINES DID SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK IF YOU DO WISH TO
SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND WE'RE
SPEAKING ON THE TO GO FIRST TO.
MAKE SURE WE'RE SPEAKING ON SB
FIVE FIVE NINE. SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. YES IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE FIVE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE DURING THIS
TIME IF YOU ARE NOT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE FIRST TWO
LINES FORTY THREE. GOOD MORNING
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU LINE FORTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WOULD HAVE TO LIVE UP
WITH THE COMMUNITY WATER CENTER
ALONG THE LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND CLEAN WATER ACTION IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE AT NIGHT.
THANK YOU LINE. SEVENTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING KIM DELFINO
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE FIVE NINE THANK YOU LINE.
EIGHTY TWO. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS GAIL BILL HANNA WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
SUPPORT SB. FIVE FIVE NINE.
LINE FIFTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
CHRIS CON REPRESENTING THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. BY.
SEVENTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
CODY BOILS IN BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA COTTON
GENERATION GROWERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE TULARE LAKE WATER BASIN
FAST STORAGE DISTRICTS ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU LINE.
EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN THIS IS BOB REED WITH
THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON
BEHALF OF DESERT WATER AGENCY
PALMDALE WATER DISTRICT AND THE
VALUE ATWATER COALITION IN
SUPPORT. LINE SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
IN HUMANITY HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE MAYOR RIGHT NOW IN SUPPORT.
BY TWENTY NINE. FIVE GOOD
MORNING PARADIGMATIC HE IS IN
THE DISTRICT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
Là NINE EIGHTY SEVEN. I
REMEMBER THINKING NOBODY WITH
ENERGY FEET IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. AND ARMY ONCE AGAIN A
FINAL CALL IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO. TO CHAIR NO ONE ELSE IS A
PART OF ME WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
PHONE LINES THAT HAVE SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT. I'M GONNA GO TO LINE.
SEVENTY SEVEN. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE FIVE TO LINE.
EIGHTY SIX. THIS IS IAN LEMAY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FIVE NINE. AND ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN IF YOU WISH TO
OUR QUEUE UP PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN. SECRETARY
APPEARS THAT WE HAVE NO WENT
OUT TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
HAVE- NOPE NOPE WE DO HAVE A
ONE PERSON WISHING TO ADDRESSES
ON FIVE FIVE NINE. SB FIVE FIVE
NINE. THIS IS PORTATO. GOOD
AFTERNOON OR GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRAND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PAUL MCGAVIN WE'RE WITH
CALIFORNIANS WHO ABSOLUTELY
KNOW THE NUMBER OF WORDS IN OUR
ORGANIZATION OR UP TO THE
ORGANIZATION BY ANYONE ASK ONCE
DURING YOUR- USER WE'RE NOT
PLAYING GAMES YOU'RE DONE WE'RE
VERY CLEAR PEOPLE WANT TO BUY
BY THE COMMITTEE RULES YOUR WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE-
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IF YOU
WANT TO. CLOWN THE COMMITTEE
AND BY EVERYTHING ELSE THANK
YOU MAY LEAVE NOW ALL RIGHT.
SEE NOBODY ELSE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FINANCES OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BE NICK AGAIN GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES NOT
INCLUDED IN THE STATE SPENDING
PLAN THE BILL REQUIRES THAT ARE
MADE OF WATER RESOURCES UPON
APPROPRIATION TO EXPAND SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SUBSTANCE REPAIRS
COSTS FOR VARIOUS CANALS AND
AQUEDUCTS PROJECTS. THIS BILL
DOES NOT INCLUDE FUNDING FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO ADMINISTER
THE SPECIFIED FUNDING AS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WILL BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
I SEE NO QUESTIONS- OF COURSE
THIS BILL IT IS BEING MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE WHICH WILL BE
DISPENSED OF- AND- THE COMING
MINUTES- PROJECT CLOSE I THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES I. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR ALL RIGHT AT
THIS POINT WE ARE GOING TO
READ- FROM THIS REGULAR ORDER
BUSINESS THAT THE BILLS THAT
ARE BEING MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE FOR OUR NEXT. HEARING. SB
FOUR GONZALES SB FORTY EIGHT
LEMOND S. B. TWO FOUR TWO
NEWMAN SB THREE THIRTY DRAWS-
SB THREE FIVE FOUR SKINNER SB
THREE EIGHT NINE DODD. SB FOUR
NINE ONE NIELSEN SB FIVE ONE
ZERO PAN. SB FIVE THREE NINE
HERTZBERG SB FIVE FIVE TWO
HERTZBERG SB FIVE FIVE NINE HER
TITLE SB SIX THREE SEVEN NEWMAN
SB SIX FIVE ZERO STERN SB SIX
SIX SEVEN ROTH WONDERFUL AND
I'M SORRY FOR CLIP TWENTY TO
GAVEL DOWNING GAVEL DOWN AGAIN
NOW WE CAN JUST MOVE STRAIGHT
ON OKAY THANK YOU FOR. PHONE
LINES ARE DONE NO THERE IS NO
PUBLIC COMMENT DURING THE REST
OF THIS AND WE WILL DISPENSE
OF. NOT YET TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVEN BILLS THAT ARE ON THE
SUSPENSE FILE- WE'LL GET JUST
THE HOUSEKEEPING FIRST AND THEN
WE'LL WAIT FOR THE SENATE TO
GET THEIR CHAIRS SO WE CAN
START SAME TIME AS IS CUSTOMARY
IN THIS HOUSE BEFORE WE START
I'D LIKE TO THINK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND- THE REPUBLICANS. MY
COMMITTEE STAFF AND REPUBLICAN
STAFF ALL THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK IT'S VERY
APPRECIATE ESPECIALLY IN THESE
TRYING TIMES. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE IN
THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANT'S OFFICE-
IN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PERSONNEL. AND MANY OTHERS WHO
HELPED ENSURE THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS CONTINUES DURING THESE
VERY TRYING TIMES AGAIN. AND
ALSO ALL OF OUR PERSONAL STAFF
WHO WE ALL KNOW DO THE REAL
HARD WORK- I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK OF COURSE MY VICE CHAIR
WHO WHO ALWAYS MAKES THIS.
EASIER FOR ME- AND WILL BE
SWITCHING PLACES SO THAT HE
WILL MAKE SURE I READ
EVERYTHING CORRECTLY I THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
SIT ON THIS COMMITTEE IT IS A
LOT OF BILLS AND YOU ALL HAVE
DONE A VERY GOOD JOB IN KEEPING
ON TOP OF IT SO THANK YOU. AND
SO WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED SEVEN
BILLS WE ARE GOING TO DISPENSE
OF TODAY IF THERE IS A BILL
THAT YOU THOUGHT MIGHT COME UP
AND IT WASN'T HEARD EARLIER IN
ITS NOT. DISPENSED OF IN ANY
WAY BUTYOU KNEW IT WAS IN OUR
COMMITTEE IT IS BECAUSE THE
AUTHOR OF THAT BILL ASKED THAT
IT BE PULLED- IT MADE IT TO
YOUR BILL SO I KNOW THAT. THERE
WAS A FEW OF THOSE IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR- CERTAIN BILLS BY
CERTAIN AUTHORS THEN YOU DON'T
HEAR THEM THAT COULD BE THE
REASON WHY YOU MIGHT WANT TO
CHECK THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE THIS
AGENDAS CAN BE ORGANIZED
ALPHABETICALLY BUT WE'RE GONNA
GO IN REVERSE ALPHABETICAL
ORDER BECAUSE THE W'S ALWAYS GO
LAST IF NOT- OUT OF FAIRNESS
BUT WE'RE GONNA START ACTUALLY
WITH THE COMMITTEE BILLS AS
WELL. AS V. WEBSITE THE YOU CAN
GO TO FOLLOW ALONG IS A P. R.
O. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT G.
O. V. THAT SHOULD HAVE THE
AGENDA ON IT HAVE WE HEARD FROM
THE SENATE NOT YET IF MISTER
BIGELOW WOULD YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. SO WE NEED A FILLER
MOMENT HERE BECAUSE THE SENATE
HAS NOT COME FROM AND CONVENE
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
ESSENTIALLY DID- WHAT THE
CHARGES THAT WE ALL KNOW THAT
OUR STATUS BEHIND THE SCENES TO
A GREAT DEAL OF THIS WORK DOING
THE PREPARATION AND MAKING SURE
THAT WERE INFORMED AND STE AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE A RENDERED. COLLECTIVE
DECISION WHEN THERE'S PRO OR
CON I APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
EFFORTS I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS WHO'VE TAKEN THE TIME
TO PRESENT THEIR BILLS IN AN
OPEN DIRECT MANNER SO THAT WE
COULD UNDERSTAND THEM AND- I
APPRECIATE ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE THEM. FOR TAKING THE
TIME INTENSE SITUATION. WHEN IT
WAS NECESSARY TO AMEND THEIR
BILLS. SO THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
AND THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND-
WE'RE GOING TO ENJOY THE REST
OF THE DAY WE'LL GET THROUGH
IT. WILL TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND
GO THROUGH IT THE DOES ANYONE
ELSE ON THE COMMITTEE WISH TO
SAY A FEW WORDS. I MEAN. YEAH.
RIGHT. A LOT OF. THANK YEAH.
THAT NUMBER. WE'RE CALLING ON.
BEHALF. THE OUT OF NETWORK.
THIS LIST START I FORMALLY WHAT
ALL RIGHT GONNA GO AHEAD AND
START EVEN THOUGH THE SENATE
HASN'T STARTED BECAUSE ALTHOUGH
MY DOCUMENT IS LINED UP IN
REVERSE ALPHABETICAL ORDER THE
REPUBLICANS DOCUMENT IS LINED
UP IN NUMERIC ORDER SO IT IT
MAY TAKE AWHILE TO US ANNOUNCE.
THE VOTES CORRECTLY SO JUST A
WARNING SORRY GUYS. YOU KNOW I
LIKE TO GET YOU OUT OF HERE AS
QUICK AS POSSIBLE THE NEW.
ON
THE OTHER. I DON'T KNOW OKAY.
TWO WOMEN HE'S OFTEN. ALL RIGHT
WE ARE GOING TO START IF THE
SERGEANT WILL PASS OUT THE
DOCUMENT TO THE MEMBERS. AGAIN
WE'RE GOING TO GO A LITTLE
SLOWER THAN I USUALLY LIKE TO
GO BECAUSE WE JUST HAVE A
SORTING ISSUE FINE OKAY. THE
FIRST BILL BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
IS S. B. EIGHT TWENTY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION I SEE A MOTION BY
MISS CARILLO A SECOND BY DOCTOR
QUIRK SB EIGHT TWENTY BYE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION DEALS WITH
FAIRGROUND REVENUES. DO YOU
PASSED AS AMENDED TO READ ALLOW
USE OF ADJUSTED GROSS RECEIPTS
EXTEND THE TIME FRAME FOR
TRANSFERRED FUNDS THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. OKAY IF IT'S
OKAY WITH THE MOTION MAKER IN
THE SECOND- I'M GOING TO
REPLACE THAT MOTION AND SECOND
FOR. THE EVERY THE REST OF THE
SUSPENSE FILE. OKAY S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY FIVE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE HAS TO
DO WITH A LOCAL TAX
ADMINISTRATION TO PASS A ROLL
CALL. SB EIGHT EIGHT FIFTEEN
THE COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
MEAT AND POULTRY FEES. TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. S. B. EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT IS A COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
SURPLUS STATE PROPERTY DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL WE'RE GONNA PIES
I WAS HOPING THE SENATE WOULD
HAVE STARTED WILL GIVE US SOME
TIME TO GET THIS IN ORDER IF
ANYONE NEEDS TO TAKE A BREAK
FEEL FREE TO DO SO WE WILL
RESUME AS SOON AS- WE CAN.
SORRY GUYS.
I'LL BE ABLE.
CORRECT- FOUR DOLLARS CANCEL
POSSIBLE RIGHT DIDN'T. I WANT
TO LOOK AT. RIGHT I AND HERE.
YEAH RIGHT. AND-
NOW. WITH THE.
YEAH.
YEAH. AND- YEAH RIGHT WOW.
BUT. UHHUH- RIGHT. THIS IS YOUR
LIFE YEAH GOOD. THANK. YOU SHOT
THAT MIGHT.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE
READY WHAT WELL GO AHEAD I
THINK WE'VE GOT ENOUGH THAT WE
CAN GET THROUGH SOME OF THESE.
I RATE THE MIKE'S BACK ON RIGHT
OR LIVE YES OKAY. WE ARE ON
WILK. WOULD YOU JUST TO OF THE
RECIPIENT. OKAY. THIRTEEN ON
THE BACKS OKAY RIGHT RIGHT
THERE WE ARE SB FIFTY EIGHT
SENATOR WILK EDT PRIDE OF
REMIND PEOPLE WE HAVE THE
MOTION IN THE SECOND FROM
PREVIOUSLY. HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB
FIVE FORTY SIX WILK I FOSTER
PROGRAM. THREE WIENER.
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES PER IN
PROBATION. DO PASSED AS AMENDED
TO ACCEPT AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
RELATED TO COURT MINUTES THAT
GETS OUT ON A. B. ROLL CALL SB
ONE TEN WIENER S. U. D.
TREATMENT INCENTIVES DO PASSED
AS AMENDED TO MAKE THE BENEFIT
OPTIONAL. THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB TWO
TO ONE WIENER HEALTH INSURANCE
TIMELY ACCESS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB TWO FIFTY TWO WIENER
RECALL TESTING HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
SB THREE FOURTEEN WIENER
RESTAURANTS RELIEF DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO MAKE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES THAT GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
SB THREE THREE NINE WIENER ROAD
USAGE CHARGE. DO PASSED WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO ADD
IMPLEMENTATION IMPLEMENTATION
DATE OF JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND TO ELIMINATE
STATE AGENCY WORKING GROUP AND
INSTEAD REQUIRE CAL STA TO
CONSULT WITH OTHER STATE
ENTITIES. THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL SB THREE FIFTY SEVEN
WIENER IT HAS TO DO WITH
LOITERING DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ACCEPT AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
RELATED TO SEALING OF RECORDS
SB FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN WIENER
LIKE IT'S ON THE BACK IT'S OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL I'M SORRY. SB
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN WIENER
GENERAL PLAN ANNUAL REPORTS DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO REDUCE THE
SCOPE AND PROVIDE CHATTERING
OUT AMENDMENTS THAT GETS OUT
WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
SB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT WIENER
HOUSING PROJECTS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WELL NOW MOVES TO MR
WHITE HOUSE SKI SB FIVE OH ONE
WHITE HOUSE SKI. GOVERNMENT
CLAIMS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SB EIGHT OH SEVEN WHITE HOUSE
SKI CIVIL RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT DO
YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE A
TECHNICAL CHANGE THAT GETS OUT
WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
S. B. FORTY ONE. AMBERG GENETIC
TESTING. DO PASSED AS AMENDED
TO TAKE OTHER AMENDMENTS
RELATED TO WORKPLACE HEALTH AND
SAFETY LAWS THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB TWO
FORTY ONE AMBERG CIVIL ACTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE
LANGUAGE RELATED TO REMOTE
TESTIMONY THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB THREE
FORTY NINE AMBERG S. U. D.
PATIENT RIGHTS TO PASS THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL SB
THREE SIXTY SIX AMBERG
AUTOMOBILE DISMANTLING STRIKE
TEAM TO PASS ON IT A ROLL CALL
SB THREE NINETY NINE AMBERG
SPECIALIZED LICENSE PLATES
HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB FOUR TWENTY
AMBERG UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
TASK FORCE HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
SIX SIXTY FIVE AMBERG VETERANS
EMPLOYMENT PREFERENCE DO PASSED
AS AMENDED TO REMOVE RETENTION
PROVISIONS EASE IMPLEMENTATION
AND MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO MR STERN SB
SIXTY THREE BY MR STERN FIRE
PREVENTION DO PASSED AS AMENDED
TO REVISE BUILDING STANDARD
ADOPTION PROVISIONS CHANGE
REPORT DUE DATE AND THE NAME OF
THE TASK FORCE AND LOWERED THE
ADVANCE PAYMENT ABOUT. AMOUNT
225% WITH THE DIRECTOR'S
DISCRETION. THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB TWO
EIGHTY FOUR STERN WORKERS
COMPENSATION. DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO INSERT POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS INJURY- AND THAT
INCLUDES POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS
DISORDER CHECK IT OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING IN SB
FOUR OH SIX STERN OIL AND GAS
WELL DATA DO PASSED WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS REVISED
APPLICATION AND DATA
REQUIREMENTS AND REQUIRE ALL
NOTICES OF VIOLATION AND ORDERS
OF THE SUPERVISOR TO BE POSTED
ON THE DIVISION'S INTERNET
WEBSITE BACK IT'S OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE STERN ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES DO PASS WITH AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO MOVE EFFECTIVE
DATE TO TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
ADD REDUCTION OF TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS AND CRITERIA AIR
POLLUTANTS LIKE IT'S OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB FIVE
FIFTY ONE STERN. AS SEVEN FORTY
HOLDING COMMITTEE SB SIX FIFTY
EASTERN NURSING HOME FINANCIAL
REPORTS DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING IT'S
GOING TO VOTE ON ANYTHING
TODAY. ONE OR TWO. SB SIX
NINETY THREE STERN THE COUNCIL
ON GENOCIDE EDUCATION THAT HAS
BEEN MADE TO YOUR BILL AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR SB SEVEN
NINETY STERN WILDLIFE
MITIGATION CREDITS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REVISE AND RE CASTS
A PROGRAM WITHIN AN EXISTING
MITIGATION BANKING PROGRAM AT
DFW THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING WELL NOW
MOVE ON TO MISS SKINNER. SB.
SIXTEEN. SIX SKINNER. FOR. HE
THAT'S OKAY SB SIXTEEN SKINNER
POLICE PERSONNEL RECORDS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
RELEASE OF SUSTAINED YOU
SUPPORT COMPLAINTS THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL SB
EIGHTEEN SKINNER GREEN HYDROGEN
HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB TWENTY
SEVEN SKINNER NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO EXTEND THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE ONE YEAR
CLARIFY BOTH CARBON REMOVAL AND
GHG EMISSION REDUCTION PROJECTS
ARE ELIGIBLE AND DIRECTED THE
NRA TO WORK WITH ALL RELEVANT
AGENCIES THAT IS HOW THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING WHICH.
SB SIXTY FIVE SKINNER PREGNANCY
ASSOCIATED REVIEW COMMITTEE TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE MOM
THE BEST PILOT IN RELATED
PROVISIONS THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL SB EIGHTY ONE
SKINNER SENTENCING TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ACCEPT AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS RELATED TO
EVIDENTIARY STANDARD IF. SB
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
THANK YOU SORRY SB THREE FIFTY
FOUR SKINNER FOSTER YOUTH
PLACEMENT. TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO RESOLVE FEDERAL FUNDING
ISSUES IT MAKES OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES THAT GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
SB FIVE TWENTY FOUR SKINNER
PATIENT STEERING. TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE SELF INSURED
PLANS INCLUDING MULTI EMPLOYER
TAFT HARTLEY PLANS THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL SB TWENTY
THREE RUBIO STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. I'M SORRY I'M GONNA HOLD
FOR JUST A MINUTE I THINK I
MIGHT HAVE MISSED A BILL WHICH.
I DON'T RESTAURANTS. NO I KNOW
OKAY YEAH THIRTEEN I THINK
WE'RE I PASS I S. IT OKAY I DID
NOT MISS A BILL. S. B. C. TWO.
RUBIO INSURANCE REPORTS HOLDING
COMMITTEE SB TWO SIXTY THREE
RUBIO IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AND MAKES OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES LIKE IT'S
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
SB FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT RUBIO
READING INSTRUCTION FOR
TEACHERS DO YOU PASSED AS
AMENDED WITH TECHNICAL AND
CONFORMING AMENDMENTS THAT GETS
OUT WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
RUBIO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS. GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. SB SIX SEVENTY
EIGHT RUBIO HOMELESSNESS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE SB SIX EIGHTY TWO
RUBIO RACIAL DISPARITIES
ADVISORY COUNCIL TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ADD ADDITIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB EIGHT
OH FIVE RUBIO FORMING ARTS
GRANTS DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING WILL
MOVE ON TO MISTER ROTH SB
NINETY SEVEN BY RAZA TYPE ONE
DIABETES TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
OR TAKE A BREAK FOR JUST A
SECOND LET THE AND A CATCH UP
AND TO. MAKE SURE WE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE DOING.
ALL RIGHT I GUIDED
THE WAY I DO IT YOU READY I'M
HAVING A HARD TIME ALL RIGHT
READY MOVING ON SB SIX SIX
SEVEN ROTH VETERANS PROPERTY
TAX EXEMPTION DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ALLOW OTHER SIMILAR
LEGAL ENTITIES TO FILE A CLAIM
BACK IT'S OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB EIGHT
OH TWO ROTH YU'RE A PRIVATE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ALIGN WITH
CURRENT TERM. LIMIT LAW THAT
GETS OUT WITH THE REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING SB EIGHT OH THREE
ROTH BOARD A BARBER IN
COSMETOLOGY TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB EIGHT OH SIX. ROTH
SUNSET EXTENSIONS DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO ADDRESS POST
GRADUATE LICENSE AND NARROW THE
USE OF CONFIDENTIAL REPRIMAND.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. SB TWO TWENTY FOUR
PORTANTINO MENTAL HEALTH
INSTRUCTION TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO REPLACE INCREASE WITH EXPAND
REGARDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB TWO
FIFTY FIVE PORTANTINO
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB THREE
EIGHTY ONE PORTANTINO CALTRANS
SURPLUS PROPERTY DO PASSON A
ROLL CALL. SB FIVE SIXTY TWO
PORTANTINO HEALTH INSURANCE
AUTISM DO PASSES AMENDED TO
CLARIFY SEVERAL PROVISIONS THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. SB SEVEN FIFTEEN
PORTANTINO HUNTING LICENCES TO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB
THREE OH SIX PAN TREATMENT FOR
STDS DO PASS AS AMENDED REMOVED
FAMILY PACKED AND OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL. SB THREE SIXTY
NINE PAN YOLO BYPASS FLOOD
CONTROL DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
SB FOUR TWENTY TWO PAN
PROFESSIONAL REGISTRY DO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB FIVE TEN
PAN HEALTH COVERAGE FOR TESTING
AND IMMUNIZATIONS TO PASS ON A
B. ROLL CALL. SB FIVE NINETY
EIGHT PAN SACRAMENTO REGIONAL
TRANSIT YOU PASS ON OF THE ROLL
CALL. SB SEVEN FORTY TWO PAN
VACCINATION SITES TO PASS ON A
B. ROLL CALL. SB THREE THIRTY
SIX OH CHOI BO PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDERS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
SB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE A CHOI BO
PRESCHOOL PILOT PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB SEVENTY SIX
NIELSEN EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB TWO
THIRTY TWO NIELSEN ET DE
HOLDING COMMITTEE SB FOUR NOW
ONE NIELSEN NITROUS OXIDE
ENFORCEMENT HOLDING COMMITTEE
SB TWO FORTY TWO NEWMAN PPD
REIMBURSEMENT DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO EXCLUDE MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLANS THAT GETS
OUT OF THE ROLL CALL. SB TWO
SIXTY SIX NEWMAN CHINO HILLS
STATE PARK TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN NEWMAN
NURSE STAFFING REPORTS TO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB SIX SIXTY
NEWMAN PAID SIGNATURE GATHERS
TO PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL
MOVING ON TO MISTER MEN SB TWO
SIXTY FOUR BY MEN GUN SHOWS ON
STATE PROPERTY DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO PROHIBIT GUN SHOWS
AT FACILITIES IN THE THIRTY
SECOND. AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT
INCLUDING TE OC FAIR AND EVENT
CENTER THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL SB FIVE TWELVE MEN
FOSTER YOUTH IN HIGHER
EDUCATION TO PASS AND IN A ROLL
CALL SB SIX OH SEVEN MEN.
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO REALIGN
THE SUNSET REVIEW DATES ON
SEVEN REGULATORY BOARDS AND
MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES
THAT GETS OUT IN A ROLL CALL SB
SIX FIFTY FOUR MEN A CHILD
CUSTODY DO PASS AS AMENDED
EXCEPT AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
RELATED TO NOTIFICATION THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL SB
SIXTY NINE MCGUIRE GREAT
REDWOOD TRAIL DO PASSES MET
WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
RENAME THE NC ARE A THE GREAT
REDWOOD TRAIL AGENCY AND
SPECIFY AGENCY MEMBERSHIP THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL SB
EIGHTY MCGUIRE COMMERCIAL
FISHING DO PASSED WITH
TECHNICAL CLARIFICATION THAT'S
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. SB NINETY EIGHT MCGUIRE
MEDIA ACCESS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ACCEPT AUTHOR AMENDMENTS
CLARIFYING CRIMINAL LIABILITY
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
SB TWO OH SIX MCGUIRE SEASONAL
FIREFIGHTERS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB SEVEN SIXTEEN MCGUIRE
HABITAT RICH HABITAT
RESTORATION TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB FIVE FIVE FIVE MCGUIRE
TRANSIENT OCCUPANCY TAX
COLLECTION HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB
FORTY SEVEN LIMON ORPHAN WELLS
DO PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL SB
FORTY EIGHT LEMOND A MEDIC CAL
BENEFITS DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SB FIFTY LEMOND EARLY LEARNING
AND- EARLY LEARNING AND CARE TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO CENSOR
PRESCHOOL EXPANSION IN TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT REQUIRE REPORT
REMOVED DEVELOPMENTAL
ASSESSMENT LANGUAGE REMOVE
CONTRACTOR ANTS FOR LANGUAGE
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. SB TWO NINETY SIX
LEMOND CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SB THREE SIXTY EIGHT LEMOND
HEALTH COVERAGE DEDUCTIBLES TO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE LEMOND BIOMARKER
TESTING DO PASS ON IN A ROLL
CALL. SB SEVEN OH TWO LEMOND
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS DO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN THE MON CAL SO
PROGRAM DO YOU PASSED AS
AMENDED TO PRIORITIZE REGIONS
WITHOUT FOUR YEAR COLLEGES
DEFINED DATA BE REPORTED AND
ALLOW DATA SHARING AND SELF
REPORTING BACK IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL MOVING ON TO MISS
LEYVA SB TWO FIFTEEN BY LEYVA
DNA EVIDENCE TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT BY
LEYVA DISALLOWED COMPENSATION
TO PASS ON A ROLLED UP CALL SB
TWO NINETY NINE LEYVA VICTIM
COMPENSATION DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED EXCEPT AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS RELATED TO TORTILLA
VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB
THREE SEVENTY TWO LEYVA AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL SB. THAT'S
CORRECT THERE COMING UP THIS
SUNDAY SB FIVE TWENTY THREE
LEYVA THE CONTRACEPTIVE EQUITY
ACT THAT BECOMES A TO YOUR BILL
SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN LEYVA
DIRECT CONTRACTOR LIABILITY TO
PASS ON TO BE WILL CALL ALL
RIGHT. LOOK AT THE DEATH KEEP
GOING GOING ON TO MR LAYERED.
FOLLOWING RIGHT ALONG THAT
THERE SB THREE NINETY LAYERED
EDT RECESSION PLAN TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL SB FOURTEEN LAYERED
SEA LEVEL RISE TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
LAYERED REDEVELOPMENT HOLD IN
COMMITTEE SB FOUR FORTY SEVEN
LAYERED CIVIL ACTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ACCEPT AUTHOR
AMENDMENTS RELATING TO JUDICIAL
COUNCIL REPORTING THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL AB FOUR FIFTY
SIX LAYARD FIRE PREVENTION DO
PASSED WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO EXPAND PERMIT COORDINATION
AND REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. SB FOUR NINETY SIX
LAYERED. I HAD A RIVER FLOOD
CONTROL DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SB SIX NINETEEN LAYERED ORGANIC
WASTE DO PASSES AMENDED TO
REVISE AND RECAST THE PROGRAM
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. MOVING ON TO COM
LAGER ACA THREE COM MOTOR
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE DO PASSED
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
MAYBE NOT A SENATOR JONES SB
TWO TWENTY SEVEN OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES HOLDING COMMITTEE SB
THREE FIFTY EIGHT JONES MAIL
THEFT HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SB FOUR
SEVENTY JONES COMBINED HUNTING
AND FISHING LICENSE HOLDING
COMMITTEE. SB FIVE THIRTY FOUR
JONES DENTAL HYGIENE BOARD DO
PASSES MANAGE DELETE
APPOINTMENT SECTION THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL SB FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT JONES LPS HEARING
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO ACCEPT
AUTHOR MOMENTS RELATED
COURTROOM ACCESS THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB
EIGHTY FOUR OR TA THE OIL AND
GAS WELLS DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB ONE
AWAIT- TADO FOOD REPORT HOLDING
COMMITTEE SB THREE NINETY
THREE- TADO MIGRANT CHILD CARE
DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO DELETE
REFERENCE TO STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE PROVIDE
CHATTERING OUT OF MOMENTS THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL SB FOUR
OH TWO ARE TALL THOUGH
HEALTHCARE PAYMENT REFORM
PILOTS HOLDEN COMMITTING. SB
FOUR TWENTY OR TO OTHER
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA SCREENING DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB FOUR
FOUR ONE OR TWO OTHER HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IN GERIATRICS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB FIVE FIVE
NINE OR TADO WATER CONVENIENCE
FUNDING. TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE D. W. OUR STATE WATER
BOARD AND DFW TO ENSURE FUNDING
SUPPORTS PUBLIC BENEFITS
REQUIRE D. W. R. TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE DIRECTOR
TO PORTION FUNDING BASED ON
CERTAIN FACTORS. AND THREE
REQUIRE BENEFICIARIES TO PURSUE
COSTS FROM RESPONSIBLE PARTIES
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING IN SB SIX OH NINE-
TALL THE CALFRESH TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE CALPERS
E. AND T. EXPANSION THAT GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. SB SEVEN OH THREE- TADO
DISEASED ANIMAL LAB SERVICES TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL MAYBE NOT A
SENATOR WEST SO SB FOUR SIXTEEN
WEST OF HIGHER EDUCATION IN
PRISONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY FUNDING AND IN PERSON
REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE CDC OURS
COST NEUTRAL. ADD CERTIFICATES
OTHER TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
THE MAMMOTH TECH IS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB FIVE
EIGHTY NINE WESO CLEAN ENERGY
WORKFORCE TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB SIX TWENTY FOUR WEST
SO ENVIRONMENT EQUITY AN
OUTDOOR ACCESS THAT BECOMES A
TO YOUR BILL. SB SIX EIGHTY
FOUR WEST SO CALIFORNIA BORDER
COMMISSION DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN WEST SO TRAUMA
KITS HOLDEN COMMITTEE MOVING ON
TO SENATOR HERTZBERG SB TWO
SIXTY TO BAIL DO PASSES AMENDED
EXCEPT AUTHOR MOMENTS REMOVING
ZERO BAIL THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL SB TWO SIXTY SEVEN
HERTZBERG PROPERTY TAX SOLAR
FLIP DO PASSED WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING SB THREE FORTY FOUR
HERTZBERG HOMELESS SHELTERS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB FIVE THREE
NINE HERTZBERG PROPOSITION
NINETEEN IMPLEMENTATION TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL SB FIVE FIFTY
TWO HERTZBERG DROUGHT PLANNING
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO LIMIT THE
CONTINGENCY PLAN REQUIREMENT.
TO SMALL WATER SUPPLIERS
SERVING A. THOUSAND TO TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINE AND REQUIRE THOSE
SERVING FEWER THAN A THOUSAND
AD DROUGHT PLANNING TO EXISTING
PLANTS ASPECTS OF FIDE SECOND
TO DELETE THE PROVISION
RELATING TO CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
REPORTS AND MAKE OTHER
REQUIREMENTS IF FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE ON SB SIX FORTY SIX
HERTZBERG- THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU. SB SIX
FORTY SIX HERTZBERG JANITORIAL
EMPLOYEES TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE TO JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK IT'S OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB
THIRTY NINE GROVE EDT FRAUD
HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN GROW VIA VEHICLE TRAILERS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO DELAY
EFFECTIVE DATE FOR FIVE YEARS
THAT GETS OUT IN A ROLL CALL
DMV'S GOT ISSUES SB THREE FORTY
EIGHT GROW VETERANS HOME TASK
FORCE HOLDING COMMITTEE MAYBE
NOT A SENATOR GONZALEZ SB FOUR
CS AB EXTENSION DO PASSED WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO CONFORM
TO SB ONE FIFTY SIX THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL SB TWO
FORTY FIVE GONZALEZ COST
SHARING AND DEDUCTIBLES THAT
BECOMES A TO YOUR BILL. SB
THREE THIRTY EIGHT GONZALEZ
SUPPORT TRACKING LIST DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO NARROW IT THE
CARRIERS ADDED TO THE LIST AND
STRIKE THE AUDIT PROVISION THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB
FOUR OH THREE GONZALEZ DRINKING
WATER CONS CONSOLIDATION AT
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. DO YOU
PASS THAT ON TO BE ROLL CALL SB
FOUR FIFTY TWO GONZALEZ
IMMIGRATION AGENCY THIS BECOMES
A TO YOUR BILL AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR. SB SIX OH SIX
GONZALEZ ENHANCE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO FURTHER SPECIFY WHAT
CONSTITUTES AN ENTERPRISE WIDE
VIOLATION. AND EGREGIOUS
VIOLATION THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL. SB SIX SEVENTY ONE
GONZALEZ CLEAN FREIGHT
CORRIDORS TO PASS ON IN A ROW
ROLL CALL SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX
GONZALEZ SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION DO PASSED WITH
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO DELETE
THE STRATEGY AND INSTEAD. S. G.
C. TO CONVENE ALL THE RELEVANT
AGENCIES TWICE HERE TO
COORDINATE SUSTAINABLE
TRANSPORTATION POLICIES. AND
REVISE THE CTP PROVISIONS THAT
GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL. SB
SEVEN SEVENTY SIX GONZALEZ
WATERBOARDED SORTIE
CONSOLIDATION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE AN
UNNECESSARY DEFINITION THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
MOVING ON TO MISTER GLAZIER S.
B. FORCED I'M SORRY SEVEN FORTY
NINE BY GLAZIER MENTAL HEALTH
COUNTY SPENDING TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL SB NINETEEN BY
GLAZIER WINERY TASTING ROOMS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO RAISE THE
APPLICATION FEE TO FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY DOLLARS THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB
FOUR FORTY SIX GLAZER VICTIM
COMPENSATION TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB SIX EIGHTY SIX GLAZER
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
DISCLOSURES TO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR
GLACIER HEALTH CARE DATA
HOLDING COMMITTEE SB AIRPORT
GLAZIER CONSERVATION CORPS
TRAINING CENTER TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL SB THREE SIXTEEN
EGGMAN FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL SB TWO FORTY SEVEN
EGGMAN RARE DISEASE ADVISORY
COUNCIL DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SB THREE EIGHTY EGGMAN END OF
LIFE OPTION ACT TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ADDISON SET BACK ITS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL SB FOUR
SIXTY FIVE EGGMAN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES DO PASSED WITH
TECHNICAL MEN MEN SECONDS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL SB SIXTY TWO DID
ALSO GARMENT MANUFACTURING TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY
PIECE THREE VIOLATIONS APPLY
PER EMPLOYEE THAT GETS OUT ON
OF THE ROLL CALL SB TWO SEVENTY
DRAW SO EMPLOYEE INFORMATIONDO
PASSED B. ROLL CALL SB THREE
TWENTY ONE DROUGHT SO DOMESTIC
WORKER RIGHTS DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB
THREE THIRTY DROUGHT SO LACC DE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO PASS ON
THE B. ROLL CALL. SB SIX THIRTY
NINE COULD ALSO SUB MINIMUM
WAGE DO PASSED AS AMENDED
CONDITION THE SUB MINIMUM WAGE
AND DATE ON THE MULTI YEAR
PHASE OUT PLANET HAVING BEEN
RELEASED AND MAKING OTHER
CLARIFY CHANGES THAT GETS OUT
ON THE B. ROLL CALL. SB SIX
SEVENTY FOUR DID ALSO
CALIFORNIA JOBS PLAN ACT TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO MODIFY THE
SCOPE OF RELEVANT PUBLIC
AGENCIES FURTHER SPECIFY WHAT
QUALITATIVE DATA MUST BE
SUBMITTED EXTEND THE SUNSET
DATE TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT PACKETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL S SEVEN THIRTY
ONE DROUGHT SO CRIMINAL RECORDS
TO PASS AS AMENDED IT TO ACCEPT
AUTHOR MEMONS DELAYING
IMPLEMENTATION THAT GETS OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL. SB NINETY NINE
WE'RE GOING ON TO MISTER DODD
BY SENATOR DODD ENERGY
RESILIENCE GRANTS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. SB ONE OH NINE DOT
EMERGENCY TECHNICAL TECHNOLOGY
OFFICE TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SHIFT THE NEW OFFICE TO HELP
OUR THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB TWO
TWO TWO DODD WATER RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM DO PASSED
WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AND
OTHER CLARIFICATIONS THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB THREE
THIRTY TWO DODD PRESCRIBED
BURNS TO PASS ON AND A ROLL
CALL NOTHING. ARE WE OKAY I'M
ESSENTIALLY MAKES SENSE ALL
RIGHT I GUESS RIGHT ON A ROLL
COUGH SB THREE EIGHTY NINE DIED
ALCOHOL TO GO DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE CONSUMER
DELIVERY SERVICE PERMIT
PROVISION AND SPECIFY THAT
ALCOHOL TO GO COULD NOT. BE
DELIVERED THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL SB FOUR NINETY FOUR
DAUGHTERS LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SB CHOATE DOLLY SIERRA NEVADA
CONF SERVIN SEED TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL SB. THREE NINETY SIX.
WHOLLY OR PARTLY MEGAN IS NOT
ONLY OUR GALLON DALLY I'M
CHáVEZ A LONG TIME AGO SB
THREE NINETY SIX DALLY ELECTRIC
UTILITY VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
DO YOU PASS ON A ROLL CALL SB
THIRTY SEVEN CORTESE CORTESE
LIST PROJECTS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CREATE A SEQUENCE
ACTION FOR SPECIFIED CORTEZ HE
LETS PROJECTS ARE REQUIRED LEAD
AGENCIES TO FILE NOTICE WITH
OPR THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL. SB SIX NINETY TWO CORTEZ
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT THAT BECOMES A TO
YOUR BILL SB SEVEN NINETY ONE
CORTESE SURPLUS LAND UNIT TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO DELETE THE
WORKING GROUP THAT GETS OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL MOVING ON TO
MISS KOBE ADIL SB TWENTY EIGHT
BY COMING AT ALL D. I. V. C. A.
REFORM DO PASSES AMENDED TO
ONLY AUTHORIZED CPUC TO COLLECT
GRANULAR DATA THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. SB
THREE SIXTY FIVE COMING AT ALL
ELECTRONIC CONSULTATION DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL SB THREE NINETY
FIVE COMING AT ALL E. CIGARETTE
EXCISE TAX DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE EXCISE
TAX IS NOT IMPOSED ON TOP OF A
SALES TAX. ALLOW RETAILERS TO
KEEP 1% OF THE TAX REVENUE FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS MODIFY TAX
ALLOCATION PERCENTAGE AND ALL
THREE IS A THREE MILLION
GENERAL FUND LOAN TO COVER
INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL SB
FOUR SEVENTY TWO HAVE A AUTO
PAY FOR SUCCESS FINANCING
HOLDING COMMITTEE. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT SB TWO BY BRADFORD POLICE
DECERTIFICATION DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO AUTHORIZE THE BOARD
TO SUSPEND CERTIFICATIONS TO
SPECIFY CONSTITUTIONAL
STATUTORY RIGHTS ARE INCLUDED
IN WHAT IS CONSIDERED THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY OF THE BOARD
REQUIRED THAT ALL THE BOARD
MEMBERS- MUST COMPLETE A
TRAINING AUTHORIZED PER DIEM
FOR THAT TRAINING AND CLARIFY
DEFINITION OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL SB FIVE TWENTY ONE
BRADFORD MEDIC CAL VALUE BASED
CONTRACTING HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN BRADFORD
SENTENCING DO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX
BRADFORD FINES AND FEES DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO ACCEPT
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. SB SEVEN
TEN BRADFORD CONFLICT OF
INTEREST HOLDEN COMMITTEE SB
SEVEN FORTY THREE BRADFORD.
BROADBAND HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB
SEVEN NINETY SIX BRADFORD
BRUCE'S SPEECH TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL MAYBE NOT A MISTER
BORJAS SB THREE OH THREE
PROPERTY TAX DISASTER RELIEF TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO NEARLY
NARROW APPLICABILITY OF THE TAX
RELIEF PACKAGE OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. MOVING ON TO MISTER
BECKER SB SIXTY EIGHT BY BECKER
BUILDING ELECTRIC THE CATION
GUIDANCE TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
SB THREE FIFTY FIVE BECKER
COURT FEES TO PASS WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB FIVE
A FOUR BETTER VOTER
REGISTRATIONS DO YOU PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. SB FIVE NINETY SIX
RECORD GHG REDUCTIONS AND
CEMENT TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE COMPLETION OF THE
STRATEGY BY JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND REQUIRE A R.
B. TO DOCUMENT ANY FEASIBILITY
CONSTRAINTS IDENTIFIED BY THE
BOARD AND ANY RECOMMENDED
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
BACKER EDUCATIONAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSISTANCE HOLDEN COMMITTEE S.
B. E. E. SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE
BACK OR SENTENCING TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ACCEPT AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS ADDING LEGISLATIVE
INTENT LANGUAGE THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL MAYBE NOT TO
MISS BATES. SB TWO FORTY EIGHT
BY BATES SB PEAS DO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL SB FOUR FIFTY FOUR BY
MISS BATES CHILD SUPPORT HOLD
IN COMMITTEE. SB SEVEN EIGHTEEN
BY BATES ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS- BIOTECH TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. NOW MR ATKINS WERE
IN AS. OUR. S. B. ONE SEA LEVEL
RISE DO PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL
MOVING ON TO MR ARCHULETA S. B.
EIGHT OH ONE BOARDS OF
PSYCHOLOGY AND BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES DO YOU PASS ON A ROLL
CALL SB TWO FORTY FOUR
ARCHULETA LITHIUM ION BATTERIES
DO PASSED WITH AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE THE
TRAINING REQUIREMENT THAT GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING
SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT ARCHULETA
LOWER L. A. RIVER AND LOWER SAN
GABRIEL RIVER DO YOU PASS ON A
ROLL CALL SB SIX FORTY THREE
ARCHULETA HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
ASSESSMENT DO YOU PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. SB EIGHT HUNDRED ARE
TO LEAD A DEPARTMENT OF REAL
ESTATE TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
MOVING ON TO OUR FINAL AUTHOR
MISTER ALAN. SB FORTY FOR
STREAMLINED SEQUEL REVIEWED YOU
PASSED WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO ADD A LEGISLATIVE INTENT. AT
PUBLIC NOTIFICATION PROVISIONS.
AND LIST WHAT LEAD AGENCY
SHOULD CONSIDER AFTER PUBLIC
COMMENT REQUIRE ADDENDUMS FOR
PROJECTS WITH FINALLY I OURS
ISSUED BEFORE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB
SIXTY SIX ALLEN AB ADVISORY
COMMITTEE HOLD IN COMMITTEE SB
EIGHTY THREE ALLEN SEA LEVEL
RISE BUYOUT PROGRAM TO PASS ON
A B. ROLL CALL SB THREE FORTY
THREE ALLEN CHASING ARROWS DO
PASSED WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS
TO STREAMLINE AND RECAST THE
PROGRAM THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL SB FOUR THIRTY THREE
ALLEN COASTAL COMMISSION
PENALTIES DO PASSES AMENDED TO
PROHIBIT THE COASTAL COMMISSION
FROM IMPOSING CIVIL
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES ON
STATE AGENCIES THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB
FORTY THREE ALLEN SENTENCE AND
HENCE MINTS TO PASSING A BE
ROLL CALL SB SIX ELEVEN BY
ALLEN A FILM TAX CREDIT THAT
BECOMES A TO YOUR BILL. SIX
TWENTY EIGHT ALLEN EARN AND
LEARN GRANTS TO PASS AS AMENDED
MAKE CONTINGENT ON
APPROPRIATION THAT GETS OUT
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING IN
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST SB SEVEN
FIFTY TWO BY ALLEN TO DISCLOSE
ACT HOLDING COMMITTEE THAT
COMPLETES ALL TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVEN BILLS A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FOUR WHICH WILL BE GOING TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR- EITHER IS THE
PASSWORD YOU PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS. I'M GONNA WAIT TO
GAVEL DOWN FOR JUST A FEW
MINUTES BUT YOU ARE FREE TO GO.
ADJOURNS.